grève illimité pour 120 salariés Keolis
dans des dépôts du secteur Montesson
Poissy Les Mureaux Maisons-Laffitte les
employés ont cessé le travail le jeudi
13 octobre afin d'alerter contre
l'ouverture à la concurrence de leur
ligne de bus repris par la société de
transport Keolis en août 2021 il
constate une dégradation de leurs acquis
sociaux on était chez Transdev ça se
passait super bien la qualité de service
était au rendez-vous les salaires
étaient au rendez-vous l'organisation de
travail c'est fait pendant des années ça
a été conçu pendant des années ouverture
à la concurrence les règles soumis par
Madame Pécresse on rase tout on
recommence tout à zéro l'impact qui a
derrière tout ça et ben ça va aller
chercher dans dans la masse salariale
dans les conditions de travail
l'organisation de travail on demande
donc une augmentation des salaires on
demande le maintien des primes pour
l'ensemble des salariés et on demande
également que la politique sociale soit
maintenue avec des conditions sociales
de rigueur les salariés de kiolis
autocar de Lyon affirme que le
transporteur met une classique
antisocial il ne souhaite pas que les
accords d'entreprise historiques pris au
sein de Transdev soit rediscutés pour un
accord de substitution le 1er novembre
2022 ont tous nos accords d'entreprises
vont tomber donc ils vont s'effacer les
négociations ça fait plus de 6 mois on
n'arrive pas à avancer on nous donne
voilà des miettes pour l'instant c'est
des miettes alors qu'on ne monte pas
plus de ce qu'on avait avant c'est de
profiter de l'opportunité de l'ouverture
à la concurrence pour déstabiliser toute
l'organisation du territoire et puis
surtout pour mettre en concurrence pas
les entreprises mais les salariés les
uns contre les autres contactez la
direction de Keolis autocar de Lyon n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer elle indique
cependant maintenir le dialogue avec les
représentants syndicaux afin de trouver
au plus vite une issue et rétablir le
service de transport